of course fourth of july weekend among
the many things you are going to be
doing is eating one of the ways to
celebrate uh this country's birthday my
talk at the table is america's favorite
fast food restaurant is
for the eight year in a row chick-fil-a
that is according to a survey of more
than 20 000 fast food customers uh
sandwich chain jimmy johns came in
second dominoes and capes
jimmy john
came in third i know because i don't
know if i don't know everywhere i have
never had it i've never been to a gym so
in case you were wondering you know came
in last place no mcdonald's
at mcdonald's so of course that starts
the whole conversation about what is it
about chick-fil-a's it's just a chicken
sandwich right
it's the pickle polynesian sauce i
actually thought that the fact that the
fries are waffle uh oh something so
eddie clearly you are a lemonade
my man is lying and uh also the shakes i
know i feel like eggs the shakes no the
frozen lemonade and you get the diet
lemonade feel like ed filled out this
survey many many many times
and then this number two was jimmy
john's which i've never been to i know
they do a good italian sub okay see when
you hit the road on the campaign trail
sometimes the only thing there is a
jimmy john's and a chick-fil-a but where
was like popeyes and like which is my
favorite chicken
the thing is they're not as wide spread
well i have a theory about chick-fil-a
that taco bell
taco bell usually ranks pretty hot i
mean that is like my go-to late night
shawn our executive producer said taco
bell's gross
i don't know if we're supposed to say it
on national tv but
my theory is it's the lineup that you
drive past and you go what is going on
in there i know i already ate but i
gotta get a piece of that i mean you
could clearly walk into the chick-fil-a
and just order but no no no you gotta
get into the lineup the drive-through
right america you try the lemonade
lemonade okay advice there good nice
little you will appreciate that looking
forward to that